you officially decided that we were it
was definitely getting to us a little
bit we became like more emotional about
Chrissy Teigen always keeps it real even
in quarantine I mean this is honestly
unreal off the TV personality and her
hubby John Legend appeared on the first
at home version of The Ellen DeGeneres
Show on Monday via video chat and talked
about their time at home obviously this
is just like the most unreal situation
ever but of course we're holding a pie
and and you know it's just been an
unreal surreal experience for our family
and everybody out there so it's yeah
it's be crazy
Chrissy also opened up about a
conversation she had with Ellen's
producer Andy Lassner better known as
average Andy on the show Andy and I were
talking yesterday and meet it officially
decided that we were it was definitely
getting to us a little bit I we became
like more emotional about me and her
Andy who was straight up wandering
around Ellen's backyard
gotta love all the bloopers and he shows
at home it's fun to be able to be
light-hearted and make jokes and try to
make people happy and laugh about it and
but then it really hits you and and you
get equals these ups and downs and it's
what we're going through right now is
unprecedented and it's and it's unreal
and in the meantime Chrissy says she
just hopes she can make people happy
during this difficult time if we can
emerge through all of this just having
this you know newfound love and respect
for our fellow human that would be such
a beautiful wonderful thing because I
know that when we're able to be in
contact with people again I'm gonna be
so emotional and it's gonna be such a
beautiful thing to be able to touch
people's hands when I laugh at what
they're saying or touch their faces or
give my dad a hug you know it's gonna be
a beautiful experience so if we can at
least
come out of this and and and change a
bit I think that would be a really
wonderful thing as for Ellen she made
sure to give her fans some sweet words
of encouragement to lift their spirits
I've always wanted to uh to have this
show as a as a distraction as a break
from whatever's going on out there that
may be unpleasant so if you're feeling
down I want to lift you up
if you're feeling trapped I want to set
you free if you're feel like you're
going in the wrong direction I want you
to back that thing up god I love her so
much of course the show looks a lot
different these days since she's
shooting it in her living room it has
the best light and sound and because all
the other rooms in my house are filled
with toilet paper
oh and meet her crew slash wife Portia
de Rossi I want to give a big shout out
to my crew my director Porsche my camera
operator Portia my key grip Auggie what
up dog that's funny because uh Auggie is
a dog and Ellen gave a special shout-out
to the essential employees who are
putting themselves at risk
each day to help usually I walk out
people applaud me but I'm applauding you
nurses doctors hospital staff first
responders Supermarket employees truck
drivers everyone who keeps us going
thank you so much
[Music]